and
we should be live
in the next 15 seconds hopefully
this is all being recorded
all right i think that we are live
how are both of you i'm good
awesome how are you where uh
cam i'll start with you where where are
you physically in the world right now
i'm in brooklyn at my apartment
awesome and uh catherine i'm in a bunker
and uh i'm doing awesome
in a bunker hey i'd like to keep safe
all right that's fair um if uh if you're
watching the live stream
uh we will take questions here in a
little bit we're gonna have a uh
a bunch of questions in the conversation
with uh camilla about uh her book about
ethereum
um and d5 a bunch of other things but uh
leave your questions in the
live chat and we will do our best to get
all of them
answered um catherine maybe you start
what questions do you have about all of
this you are the ceo
of binance us and uh are very close to
all this so what uh what questions you
got
yeah well the best part is so ethereum
just celebrated its fifth birthday
and binance just celebrated its third
birthday and binance u.s is about to
celebrate
almost its first birthday so it really
shows that people have been in this
space a lot longer than
finance us as a platform though we're
seeing a ton of new users come in
i'm curious about things going so i
really want to learn about
the early days of when ethereum was
beginning and
kind of what drove the origins of
vitalik
and the ethereum teams to kind of build
this out of the ground so
getting people that are new to this
space familiar with the old origins of
how things got started
yeah yeah um so
the theorem story is a fascinating story
like it's
um a lot of people have told me the book
reads like a fiction novel
and that's because it's it's really you
know a roller coaster ride full of
like really interesting characters um
so the the early days of of ethereum
really started with i i think just you
know a love of bitcoin
um you know in 2012
2013 when vitalik uh started
you know thinking about all this stuff
um it was like mostly
or only bitcoin that was around then
um so vitalik went from you know he was
18 or so when he when his dad told him
about bitcoin for the first time
and at first he was like what this is uh
like digital currency not backed by
anything how can it ever have any value
but then he quickly kind of you know
started researching more and and
went like oh okay like i get it now and
became
a really like full-on die-hard bitcoiner
um and founded bitcoin magazine with me
hi elise
and then took a break from uh computer
science
uh and went all over the world
visiting the different bitcoin projects
at the time it was called bitcoin 2.0
like all these projects trying to
bring more functionality to bitcoin um
so he went to you know um amsterdam
israel different places like following
these projects
and so it was in israel uh when he was
working with colored coins and
mastercoin
that he said you know instead of like
trying to
um build specific like features
on top of bitcoin why don't we build a
more generalized
platform that can allow developers to
build anything
like whatever they dream of and we just
give give them
these lego pieces instead of like what
looks like a swiss army knife
um and so the like i said master coin
and
colored coins were like no like this is
too complicated
we are we're already kind of focusing
our resources elsewhere we're not you
know
it's not we're not really interested in
doing this so that's when vitalik said
screw it i'll do it myself
and went off and you know wrote this
year in white paper
so that's kind of the very early
beginnings of it
yeah i i often explain ethereum because
i i dumb things down because
it's hard for me to understand a lot of
these concepts and so i oftentimes call
ethereum like the plato
like you can you can mold it into
whatever you want and then that thing
can become whatever you need
um so i like the lego box as well as
something that's useful
um and is that really where um
vitalik from day one do you think he saw
the things that the projects were
later on to be built i mean we talked
about the concepts that came right out
of it
um getting kind of the early adoption
and those didn't necessarily seem like
his true plans yet here we've got
other things down the road we'll we'll
talk about d5 we'll talk about
stable coins we'll talk about um there's
other adoption cases but
did he have a list of every single
possible thing you could build with this
plato
in mind or he actually did um it's
i wrote about it recently so
in in the white paper he he said well
first of all this is a platform for
developers to build whatever they want
but here are some examples of the things
i think
would be useful to to build on on
this distributed network and he listed
stuff like
um he said sub currencies so
you know like currencies issued on top
of ethereum
um then he said financial derivatives
uh identity and reputation decentralized
autonomous organizations insurance
um prediction markets um
unchanged stock markets he it was what
he called them
so he had like this list of
applications and um
and they're all actually live today so
it's pretty amazing you know in in five
years
um what vitalik had dreamed of in
in his white paper is already alive and
working
it's true that like um
you know a lot of the like applications
developers were thinking on in the very
early days
uh probably you know never had to
have a blockchain uh you know like
weren't weren't this didn't necessarily
need
uh blockchain you know like in 2013 20
like
uh 20 in the 2017 ico hype we have we
saw like
developers traded to like put blockchain
on
on top of it everything and that of
course um
doesn't work and it's not very useful
but you know things like
um financial applications i think is
where
where these distributed networks can
really add value
so one of the things that i think most
technologists
uh experience but they don't like to
admit is
that whatever they build if it becomes
successful ends up being
massively massively more successful than
they ever imagined
is that kind of the feeling you get from
the early ethereum
team which was we saw a problem we built
something to address that problem we
thought that it could
could be valuable uh but even already
how far
ethereum or the d5 space has gotten has
kind of surprised them
oh yeah um for sure i think
you know there were in the very early
days
there it wasn't a sure thing that
ethereum would succeed you know even
even after the pre-sale even after the
launch
um i i write in the book how in
uh 2015 when the bitcoin price had you
know really slumped
they were you know really strapped for
cash uh they
they didn't have much funding to to keep
going you know to
to kind of pay developers to keep uh
working on on ethereum
uh so there were definitely moments when
people working on ethereum you know they
weren't sure whether
the project would would succeed um i
think that that was an
another important moment in ethereum's
history where you know people
in the project kind of doubted whether
it
be able to go on um both from
like uh technically because
this hacker um was draining
a project that held a big piece of eve
at the time and also because you know
kind of the the core values of ethereum
were
being questioned um so
i think you know ethereum was able to
kind of
overcome those huge hurdles you know
almost going bankrupt or i guess like
this young foundation
um being so short on cash early on um
the dow hack uh there was like another
period
when ethereum was being constantly
attacked like for a full month
called the shanghai attacks um in like
2016.
so after like overcoming
all of these hurdles i think was that
people realized okay like this thing is
actually strong enough like if it can't
survive this
i feel more comfortable um you know
developing on this platform putting
money on this platform
so it was like after the shanghai
attacks after the dao
that the that we saw like more people
building on ethereum and then
like icos taking off um yeah but it was
like
in the early days nobody was like 100
sure that ethereum would survive so
and then tell us about the process for
writing the book before we started the
live streaming here we were uh talking
about
your experience of like going into the
bookstore and seeing the book on the
shelves for the first time
uh maybe just talk a little bit about
the book itself and kind of the process
you went through to
actually learn all of this and
eventually write a book about it
sure um so
i guess you know
the whole thing started with the idea of
writing a book on ethereum
and this was in 2017
after covering the crypto boom with
bloomberg
i was a market reporter so i was like
covering it from a market perspective
and had seen like
huge price increases billions flowing
into icos
and i thought you know really the most
interesting story in this space that
hasn't been told is the ethereum story
it's the second biggest cryptocurrency
it fueled a lot of this rally and nobody
really
knows exactly you know how how this
thing started so i thought
you know it's a great opportunity for
for me to tell this story
um and so yeah i mean i had never
written a book before
it had always been my dream and it was
just like i jumped
in in into this um idea
uh i i was able to you know get an agent
um
sent this proposal to a bunch of
publishers and
i was lucky that one editor at
harpercollins like really believed in in
the idea
um and i remember i was you know just
looking through my emails for
for another presentation to like the
moment that my agent
told me that you know harford collins
was interested in the vote it was like
an all caps
email being like she loves it for for
the editor
um so so from then on it was just
you know trying to talk to absolutely
everyone involved so
um i started with like the like
chronologically
er the very core early team um
and then went on from there like uh
kind of compiled what the biggest events
were and try to talk to
all of the main people involved in each
major
ethereum like milestone and event um
to spend like the first like six months
just like full-on
researching interviewing i talked with
like over 100 people
have many many hours of interviews and
transcripts it was like
a big mess kind of going going through
all of that
um and then i just you know i had my
outline and i started you know tackling
chapter by chapter
um but it was a really a fascinating
process you know talking
with all all the people who were there
uh
you know seeing this project unfold
firsthand
and then i tried to really immerse
myself in the ethereum community
so i went with them wherever they went
so
if there was a hackathon in denver i
went there um the hackathon in waterloo
san francisco i went to defcon
in prague that defcon in osaka um
meetups so i i really tried to get a
a good sense of of the community of like
what what they were like um what music
they listened to
like what they talk about uh how they
party just like
you know just like the the color um
and get a sense of what they they were
building and and getting excited about
and i guess like
that's how i i learned about about defy
all right then my last question and then
catherine fire away is
uh the terminology decentralized finance
uh it somehow like becomes like
controversial thing that everyone like
wants to fight over who owns that word
in your opinion like what is
decentralized finance or what is defy
and is that specific to one blockchain
is that kind of a bunch of blockchains
like how do you just think about
decentralized finance and then how it
actually gets implemented uh in the
coming years
sure so decentralized finance is the
ecosystem of financial applications that
that's being built with blockchain
technology
um basically and without banks so it's
an entirely new
financial system that is stripping away
intermediaries and opening access to
anyone
who wants to use these applications it's
really lowering
barriers of entry and creating an
open financial system for the first time
um i think it's it's incredibly exciting
it's uh
you know the cypherpunk dream uh come to
life
and you know it's it's it's incredible
that this thing is actually working you
know like
um it has real users real value
uh it's not just some like dreams in a
white paper um
and i think you know i don't think
defy is specific to one blockchain
i it's kind of a fact that most of it is
happening right now
on ethereum um but
i don't think that it has to be
necessarily the case
going forward um i think you know
right now ethereum has kind of like the
the
is the best position to to be the
than blockchain to support d5
applications but
um it'll have to keep winning um
you know uh winning like
the it's developers and bringing uh your
users on it's it's not like
um i don't i don't think uh you you can
become like two conformists and be like
okay ethereum one
it needs to keep like winning people
over in the future
that's awesome um you mentioned
something that is really quite near and
dear
to the ethereum community which is all
of the eighth global events
um and how amazing it is to hear about
literally flocks of people congregating
to
denver waterloo amsterdam south africa
uh you name it
now that now that we're in uh kind of
what feels to be quite a lockdown in
terms of travel
how has this impacted the ethereum
community and how do they
how do they keep um the community strong
and
uh ideas continuing to generate i mean i
think it's amazing to see d5 basically
blossom
even though um we've not been able to
have these groups of kind of
ethereum congress uh coming together um
around the world
yeah um so i think the impact has been
that you know these hackathons and
and conferences were like the moment
where um
team members saw each other because so
many of these teams are are
decentralized and it was like
you know this like family gathering kind
of atmosphere of like oh we're together
um but in terms of development like some
someone was joking the other day on
twitter that they're getting more done
now that they they're not playing around
two different conferences
there's no beanbag room in the work from
home right
and yeah i i don't think it's it's uh
it's limited development at all i mean
you see it in
the blossoming of defy um and but
there's still
hackathons and conferences happening
online
uh obviously it's not the same but um
for example
if global had its first first d5 focused
hackathon recently hack money and
yeah and there were tons of uh projects
that um
that participated so you know there's
still hackathons going on
and and um you know people
participating in in this event so at
least you know that
the spirit hasn't completely been lost
because of
because of corona yeah where do you find
the
the most vibrant communities to be able
to talk about ethereum and chat is it
telegram discord um you know where where
can new folks that are so passionate
about ethereum plug in to learn more
um i think twitter is the place where
most
people are and i find fine conversations
they're really interesting
um many use telegram but
i i personally don't don't like it very
much like it's just
too much i can't keep track of
everything
um and lots of teams have their own
discord where they they make
announcements and and you have kind of
the
the very like hardcore community members
engaging there so
if you're very interested in like one
specific project
um i really recommend checking out uh
like specific teams discord channels too
so kami one of the things that before i
forget everyone keep hitting the like
button that's how yeah i see you guys
all in the comments that's how people
find this on youtube you hit the like
button
um in terms of uh writing the defiant
and really spending a lot of time i
think like in the weeds
trying things using these products what
has been maybe the the biggest surprise
um or the thing that you've learned uh
in actually
being a user of a lot of these products
right you've done everything from create
the
the cami tokens to use a whole bunch of
various applications here like what's
been the biggest surprise or lesson
learned
um oh that's a tough one i let's see
well i've been
i've been surprised um by
different things i think a positive
surprise very
early on when i was just you know
starting to
to use this stuff was how easy it was um
because you know reporting for for the
book
what i kept hearing was oh like dap's ux
is horrible like this is why nobody's
using this stuff
like nobody can figure out um how to use
the dex
but then like in in 2019 when when i
started looking
into defy and um and experimenting with
all these apps for the defiant i was so
surprised to see
how easy this this stuff really was and
how
um advanced the ux was like um
i think the first defy app i probably
tried was uniswap
and just like seeing this like very
clean interface
with like you know like the unicorn and
just like
two things to do like what tokens you
wanna
buy what token do you want to sell and
that's it and just be really quick
um and the idea of like
you really just need your ethereum
address and like your
metamask plugin to access all of these
applications like you
you don't need to give out any piece of
data
you don't need to create a separate
account it's really truly permissionless
and
i think that's what kind of like made
the light bulb go off in my head like
oh this is what permission list really
means it's but i can just
go and use any of this stuff um from
wherever
i am like all i need is like an internet
connection and an ethereum address
um that was pretty mind-blowing to me um
and then recently
uh i i guess like just the the growth
um the recent growth i i hadn't uh
expected this at all like i you know
like
d5 had been growing uh pretty
pretty fast um in the past year
but what we've seen these you know past
you know month or so has i mean i don't
think anyone expected this
like i remember um you know the day that
comp was
uh about to launch that compound was
about to launch the comp token
um i was like preparing to cover it for
for the defiant but i didn't like
expect it to be like such a huge deal it
was like okay like compound
finance is distributing its governance
so again let's
write a couple of lines on that but then
i was like oh like
this thing is blowing up like people are
like
depositing hundreds of millions of
dollars in compound like it's suddenly
the most valuable
defy token ahead of like maker the house
maker
um and just like the the amount of
activity
and growth that uh like liquidity mining
has
unleashed was has been a huge surprise
like i definitely didn't
didn't expect um token incentives to
to have such a huge impact
why do you think people are flocking to
this uh
you know new craze well i won't call it
a craze because it's an actual way of
um finding finance going forward but um
why do you why do you think people are
finding this so attractive
i think i think like the fact that
compound
was um the first
to well it wasn't the first two to
use token incentives because other
projects had had done it before but
um it was uh the first to like really
increase like offer significant returns
with
its uh token um and the fact that it was
compound finance like a
really established a project in d5 that
people were already using and and
finding valuable
and that you know so many
so many people um since so many people
were already using it and finding
valuable they
they already they already knew that like
the
the token itself uh would be valuable
even if it was
you know just a governance token um
and so because there were so many people
involved from like
day one the token like really
skyrocketed and
and uh like more money flowed in
and so that really set the stage for all
of the other tokens
so when compound was so successful the
because the project itself
is valuable it it really i think like
opened the floodgates for the other
tokens and people were like oh like
they accomplished the first governance
tokens and it did well so i'm gonna get
into the next one like i'm gonna
get a balancer token i'm gonna get mta
wi-fi like
all of the next ones that came um and
yeah and i think you know besides just
like
fomoing on like oh the next governance
token i think
the the concept that they're um allowing
this concept of like an ownership
economy uh like
people being able to own a piece of the
protocol
and not just use it i think you know has
really inspired
uh people as well like i i of course
like
a big part of it is just speculation but
i think another part of it
is this this new concept in
of of um of using
of you've seen finance and actually
being able to participate
so one of the questions that came from
the the audience and i forget who
uh already so i apologize that i'm not
gonna remember your name uh
was ethereum um is a
applications platform uh and obviously
has seen
a lot of success with people building on
top of it there's a new meme
uh or narrative around being money how
do you think about
is eth money is it not money is ethereum
you know
they say quote unquote only an
applications platform
like how do you see um those two
narratives playing out and are they
contradictory to each other or they
actually
uh kind of coexist um
yeah i mean
i don't think i mean i i
definitely not contradictory to each
other um ethereum being
uh a platform for applications and is
being money um i think the the question
of
ether's money um can be answered by
you know seeing what people are actually
doing with
eath so you know people are
paying for ethereum transactions with
eth people are
using eth as collateral to to back
a stablecoin which is also being used to
to to buy
stuff um so i think eth
does fulfill the
the main requirements uh for money
except that it's very volatile so that
doesn't make it a very good money
um but it it kind of um
complements that by being collateral for
a stable coin that that isn't volatile
and
and and that can be a better a better
means of exchange
so um i think if is money
um it's arguable whether it's the best
kind of money i think it is collateral
for something that is a
better money and um i think
you know the fact that it's it's money
and it's used to
pay for transaction in in transactions
in the ethereum platform
allows for ethereum itself to
to exist and for it to be a good
layer for for applications being built
on top captain what uh what other
questions do you have before we start
taking questions from the uh the
audience leave your question in the live
chat we'll get to them all but kevin
what questions you have
yeah we've got one question that says uh
do you see erc20 raining for much longer
or do you think we'll see other
standards adopted or innovated
that's an interesting one you could
break down a little bit of kind of how
erc 20 versus the other kind of variants
came out
that'd be interesting yeah so
for now uh erc20 is definitely kind of
the reigning
standard um i think you know there are
other standards that
are are have other use cases right like
the uh like the nft the erc 721
um standard that's used for
kind of to represent assets instead of
currency
um so i think uh right now those two are
the the main ones used
on ethereum and there have been other
variants that tried to improve on
on erc20 but they haven't really picked
picked off
or taken off and um i think there
you know there's a reason why erc20 is
is the main one and it's because it's
been you know tried and tested for
for a long time and um
[Music]
it's what works with every with every
ethereum application so
i think it'll be really hard to to
replace that like
something a lot better would need to
come along and there have been like
bad experiences with the new standards
like recently
um balancer
er this like ethereum uh that balancer
added
um other types of of tokens uh to its
platform but they had this
bug um that opened it up to like
to an attack so you know it's
um that's that's always kind of the the
danger with
with the new token standards that they
they haven't been been as tested as
erc20s but obviously i mean this
space is full of innovation and and
evolves
so quickly that i wouldn't be surprised
to see a different token like
challenging erc20s
okay catherine maybe just give us a
quick uh update
in terms of finance us are you guys
doing anything with
defy um you know in any form or fashion
like how do you guys think about
uh intersecting or interacting with all
of this
innovation that's happening yeah great
question um
we're definitely the easiest on-ramp
from the fiat world into the digital
world
and that's one of the trickier spots as
uh
jamie was mentioning of getting into d5
is kind of going okay i know i can get
into unisof
pretty quickly either through wallet
connect and trust wallet but how did i
get my original ethereum how do i get
into this space
um from day one so we still offer kind
of the lowest fees in america to get
into
ethereum and we're going to continue
take
take a look next week we're going to
continue on what we can punch into the
d5 space going forward because i think
the easier on-ramps we get the more this
becomes a
an accessible way for people to get
involved and
we're still such a big believer in
educating people not intimidating them
and this place is
plenty intimidating so courtesy of
cammy's book she'll be able to kind of
lower people's
barriers to entry helping them
understand the full story of ethereum
and hopefully we can
offer a full suite of defy opportunities
for folks coming soon
awesome we also we also have gotten on
the bandwagon with ethereum offering
staking which was
one of my first forays into really
enjoying the
variety of uh consensus mechanisms for
digital assets um recognizing that proof
of stake allowed me to just park it and
then continue to
you know earn the rewards on it so we
offer four staking coins
and are going to continue to add those
out as we bring them onto our platform
so those are kind of our two forays down
and down the path but stay tuned
awesome teasing and announcement is uh
is always good
uh candy one of the uh one of the
questions or a lot of the questions are
revolving around eth 2.0 um obviously we
all see
uh kind of that continue to get pushed
out further and further i guess let's
just start with one
do you think that there will be an
upgrade to eat 2.0
to transition from proof-of-work to
proof of stake and kind of how do you
just look at this whole
eth 2.0 from where we are today
yeah well i mean the question is i mean
if
if there will be ease 2.0 and i think
definitely
yes like there is very
tangible progress on that being made
right now um i think it was yesterday or
or the day before
the the test net for each 2.0
uh was launched with um thousands of
validators on five different clients so
it's a really kind of
in in a robust place to move forward
um it's definitely been pushed out and
um who knows you know face cereal was
supposed to
uh launch early or like in january and
you know we're in july so um
but i mean whether it's coming
or not it's definitely coming um
i think the
the the most interesting thing to me
will be
how eth one can continue to support all
the development that's happening
in on ethereum until if two launches
and i'm i'm seeing really encouraging
progress on on this front
with layer two solutions um so
the difference with what was happening
with icos and ethereum clogging up with
cryptokitties and all that stuff in
in 2017 is that scaling solutions were
still in the research phase back then um
ahead of this potential new uh bull
market
layer two solutions are actually live
and working um
like ck roll-ups and different
optimistic roll-ups and
um that that kind of stuff that that's
already live
so there's um an ethereum decks called
loop ring
already working uh supporting thousands
of transactions per second
and the idea is that more and more of
ethereum dapps will
go to to layer twos um and
improve the horrible uh
gas costs that that we're seeing today
um
and so i'm you know i'm really
optimistic with
layer two solutions kind of bridging
that that gap
between each one and ease to launching
all right and then a second question is
around uh the recent occ
decision so uh basically the
regulatory body or the oversight body
for federal banks came out with an
approval or a really clarification
that banks are able to hold crypto
assets
um just like they can hold other
valuable assets
do you see that changing anything um in
this defy space is that a threat to the
d5 space
and anything or any thoughts there
no i think i think it's a it's a it's
great news for crypto in general uh
because you know if if bands can
can hold crypto that means that more
people will be able to
be comfortable coming into the space and
having people um participate with crypto
through centralized
solutions i think is the first step
before getting them into decentralized
solutions um
i think maybe eventually all of finance
will be
decentralized and running on distributed
networks but
in the meantime i think definitely uh
centralized finance and d5 will
will coexist and so i think it's a great
step forward
that banks will will now be able to
custody crypto
and and get more people um you know
comfortable with
with getting involved in this space
[Music]
catherine what else you got
oh you're on me pulling up pulling up my
questions here um
so another one was uh
this is interesting question when
writing your book how did you stay
productive
and on top of the next things happening
in the space while things were moving so
quickly
um well i mean my book definitely helped
in in staying on top of things because
um i was i was like
talking with like with your community
members all the time for
for my book and and just like
researching
reading about everything that was going
on in ethereum
so i think it was thanks to my book that
i i realized
oh my god like defy is really you know
it's real you know this this thing is
the next big thing
um and that's why i started the defiant
in you know
more than a year ago um so yeah i think
i have my book to to thank for that um
it really kind of
made me stay on top of things did you
try to
cut it off and publish it at a certain
amount of chapters and then be like oh
hold on
write another 10 chapters based on
compound yeah oh my
yeah that was like always the the
challenge like
where the where to stop um writing it i
i didn't
i i i didn't want it to seem
dated so for me you know it was always
clear starting out that this was going
to be the story of the early days and
how ethereum was created and then um
the 2017 woman bus because you know
that thing like that part of history
happened like it's not going to change
so
people will be able to read it 20 years
from now and it will still hold true
um so i i knew that at least i wanted to
cover that but then like
in in the final chapters it was um
like it was a difficult decision to make
like how much
will i get into talking about defy um
so you know i i did kind of
um go over it uh
in you know obviously not not got like
so much in the weeds but
uh the final chapters were about you
know after the
this like really long bear market and
everyone
thinking ethereum was dead developers
were building all through
all through it and um and like the most
exciting
ethereum applications were were born out
of this
so yeah i did have to kind of like cut
it off at a certain point and be like
okay
i'm i'm done like this is where the
story ends
hopefully there will be a sequel
what will you name the sequel
um how how many hackers
built the new finance or something like
that right
i was thinking i was thinking it would
be more like a another
defy word that would be in there kind of
like um
i don't know the hunger games series
names or something like that
uh awesome so
one of the questions uh i have is um
you mentioned earlier uh whether eath
as money was kind of better money
right or or not how do you kind of see
that playing out and
really the thought process or the or the
framework i've used previously is like
i think most people would agree bitcoin
is decentralized digital currency and
it's got sound money principles and all
that kind of stuff
but most of the infrastructure so far
around bitcoin has been centralized
if you then flip over to the ethereum
side you've got eth
which i think generally a lot of people
say hey this might not be the best
you know type of money but all of the
infrastructure is decentralized and so
do you see
kind of a merger of um a decentralized
digital
currency like bitcoin with decentralized
infrastructure for kind of a full stack
of decentralization
uh and then if so does the
infrastructure come to bitcoin does the
bitcoin come
to you know ethan and wrapped bitcoin or
tbtc or something like that like how do
you think through that
sure so on the question of like is
better money than bitcoin i i find them
like very similar in
in terms of of being money
uh because for me the thing that
makes it not as good money
than other alternatives is its
volatility
and and bitcoin is the same way like
it's as volatile um as ethereum
so in in that way like i don't see
bitcoin as having an advantage over
ethereum
in in like being money um
in terms of like where the
infrastructure is
right now it's definitely mostly on
ethereum and
there's already this really interesting
trend of
people bringing their bitcoin over to
ethereum to take advantage of
all these different applications so um
you know this trend has really been
taking off
this year and i i see it continuing you
know more and more people
it tokenizing their bitcoin into erc20
tokens
to to use on on ethereum um of course
like
if it were to happen that uh ethereum
like layer two solutions don't work out
and one of these
emerging new layer ones are are the ones
who
like start to capture all of like
d5 development um then it could happen
that bitcoin goes
goes there but i see bitcoin as really
like
um digital gold in in cryptocurrency
uh it it it's obviously the the biggest
uh digital asset it's the first thing
that people will buy when when they get
into
crypto um it's you know what
many people will just choose as a hedge
against
the traditional uh financial system
um so i don't i don't think people will
stop
uh holding bitcoin and and i think
um it's a it's a great investment to
have in if you believe you know
centralized currencies or central bank
uh based currencies
uh are are unstable or will continue
devaluing or just
don't don't want to be dependent on uh
government issued currencies i i think
bitcoin is great
um but then that doesn't mean that
you you can't have like a derivative of
bitcoin that you can use
in these uh decentralized finance
financial applications
all right and then one more question for
me is uh gas cost
you mentioned that earlier as something
that is rising and um
uh not in the in the best situation at
the moment
uh it seems like uh whether it's bitcoin
ethereum you know many of these
networks uh are just not as scalable as
they will be one day
uh and you get high cost uh as
transactions fill up
the blockchain talk a little bit just
about you know one
your perspective on the gas cost today
but also then two
um you know kind of is e2o the
scaling solution are there others you
know and kind of where does the relief
come from those gas costs in the future
um yeah so right now uh
gas costs are are
rising um but it's still
it's still really cheap to to just uh
do like very basic uh transactions on
ethereum
so if you just want to send
cryptocurrency on ethereum it's still
going to be a few cents
um if you want to do more complicated
transactions like i don't know
like yield uh mining or i wanted to
i'm issuing nfts for a proof of
pre-order of my book
and um issuing those nfts is costing me
like
three bucks or like between three and
five bucks and it was a
one like one dollar when i first started
um doing it so
it's it's um it's a lot and i see that
the relief happening
um not with i don't think we need to
wait for
it to for for for for that
to get better um like i said i think it
will be layered to scaling solutions
that will alleviate this and that
they're working
right now so i think you know they
they are all like pretty recently
launched so
right now there aren't many ethereum
applications on them
um and there's a problem of like chicken
and egg like
you need to have many applications on
them for
for them to be actually useful um
because it
it's it's like a ux problem of like
people
not on these layer twos can't really
interact very well with people off them
so you need to have like a critical mask
going to them
um but i think you know as gas
costs keep rising people will find it
useful to to migrate
so i think um this
i mean this will be like very effective
in alleviating
this issue hopefully
awesome i have a a couple questions that
came to mind one of them
what's one story of you interacting with
either community member or developer or
vitalik
that didn't make it in the book that you
can share with us today
the most the most vivid one uh
let's see um
so so one one
one story that i i cut from the book
um because it was just like two too many
characters
was peter mccormack believe it or not
so i had to interview peter mccormack
for the book because i i wanted like a
really interesting characters
to walk me through their experiences in
the 2017
boom and so i remember
i don't know if you remember how um
peter made this
like incredible thread detailing what
his
experience was with the ico boom and how
he uh
invested as a bunch of money and then
lost it all
um so as as soon as i saw that that
thread
um i reached out and was like i want to
interview you for my book like this is
an amazing story
so it was like on the very first draft
of the book it was going in but then my
editor was like
you're like 100 pages over you have like
30 different characters
you need to you need to cut some um
so i already had like other stories uh
about like people like heroes for my
like ico part of the book so
peter had to go but he's i mean he's an
amazing dude and
um and i still love his story
[Music]
cats do you get any more i was waiting
for someone to finish washing a dish
um the it just didn't sound too good
having the water running all of a sudden
and you're just sitting here so
um the other question i have is what are
some of the
uh die hard developers in ethereum that
you think we should be paying attention
to
um and following their story as they
take ethereum to the next level
um so uh danny ryan
is is like oh so sorry about my dog
um er yeah
danny ryan is has been kind of
spearheading the uh
development of it too um preston van
loon
is uh spearheading like one of the the
main clients for each two
ben eddington as well um yeah these
throw
people kind of leading ethereum forward
so i i would
i would watch what they're doing
[Music]
awesome um are there any other things
you hope people read your book
uh and walk away with uh kind of
the the ultimate catch catchphrase for
your book that can
can get people that have never heard of
ethereum interested in it
um i i didn't like yeah that's a good
point like i should think of a good
catchphrase but uh i don't think uh
i'm coming up with a good one right now
but i think
like there are two main things that i
want people to
to walk away with from my book like one
i just really wanted to write a fun
interesting story to read like honestly
i want people who have never heard of
blockchain or crypto be able to pick up
the book
and just you know go through a fun story
about a crazy group of people
who made this idealistic project um
had a bunch of challenges to overcome
and how they
they went about kind of overcoming them
um
and then second it's this idea
of there there's an alternative to the
way
uh the world works right now so
we are very used to exceeding control
over
um of our you know assets and our data
and our information to big corporations
and
financial institutions and i think you
know what i want this book to do
is present a different uh
a different concept where you're
actually able to
um keep control over your your stuff
over your
your assets and on your data and and
your information
um and and just uh
be part of a more open
uh way uh like um
yeah like be more in control and also
uh be able to to access
uh applications more more freely just
um so people can walk away with the idea
that
there's there's a different better way
of doing things and it's coming and
developers are
working on it like it's not like a dream
like it's it's actually there and so
hopefully you know people
will at least feel the curiosity to to
take a look and and see what's going on
yeah being self-sufficient is freedom so
yeah
i co-sign with you on that
guys before uh we've only got uh about
eight or
nine more minutes left so if you're
watching right now please hit the like
button so more people can find this
on youtube and learn about all this
content uh camilla
you mentioned nfts a few times digital
art
uh domain names all these things that i
think people are starting to experiment
with
what's um kind of your analysis on is
that all
still experimentation and not yet ready
for prime time
is that going to be where maybe main
stream adoption actually comes from
how do you see that stuff um
well i think it definitely is ready for
for
prime time i think um you know
maybe and not that many people know
about this stuff and that's why it's not
uh like hit the mainstream but um i
think
just the the idea of being able to
own uh digital assets it's really
powerful and it's part of
the theme that i was talking about
earlier you know this new ownership
economy where where you are in control
and
and nfcs are a huge part of it i mean um
right now in the same way that you
have your bank trusting your money when
you're interacting with
a lot of the you know stuff you use
online
um you have companies uh
you're trusting companies with your
digital assets and
like a great example is um games
and in-game items uh so gaming is
like i i i'm not like into it but i know
it's a huge industry
um there's like many billions of dollars
transacted in
in-game items right now um and what
nfts uh can do is
allow people to actually own these items
so if the
like one day the game that you're
playing on
uh goes bankrupt or dies or leaves or
or whatever or like decides to to
censor you and kick you out of the game
you're still you can still own those
those items
and they're yours to trade on on a
decentralized exchange
or or wherever uh so i think that's a
really
interesting use case um and then like
another use case that's also already
happening is
um nfts for
for art and and for objects
like um like i don't know like clothing
items
um and you know like tokenized
um items like assets and
i think you know this is really
interesting because it it allows
creators to to
um actually realize the the full value
of of their
of their creation you know they they
tokenize their
say a work of art um they they put the
token
on on a decentralized exchange and
now they have access to earnings on like
the primary market which
they they usually do but also of the
secondary market so
when when people start trading that
token and the value goes up
um the artistic can can
actually gain from from that well right
now
uh you know like all these like like
collector items
they start trading on the secondary
market but like creators never see a
piece of that so that's like another
really
interesting use case for for nfts um and
then just like
fun stuff like my proof of pre-order
tokens and
i just like more experimental uh things
like that
um that's worth nfts they're fun
yeah yeah cryptokitties you know like
collectibles
um yeah there's so many use cases
popping up uh it's definitely like the
crazier side of
of ethereum all right before we uh we
wrap up here
um catherine if i see one more question
about
an update on the states for by dance us
you know i had to create a i had to
create a web page just dedicated to all
the people asking when
florida when connecticut when texas were
new york when north carolina
when georgia when louisiana went alabama
i memorized them guys don't you worry
um we've got a website i'll
shoot it out follow on this link please
sign up and we'll let you know when your
state
is live for finance us um but but safe
to say that binance u.s is trying to get
into every state correct
oh absolutely and since day one um
we're just going through the state
regulations required state by state
um it's like trying to get into college
in every single state you know
we let you in the last ones you got to
fill out different essays
and uh you know get those grades up so
we're uh we're working on our way
through those states and
my goodness we're all gonna have a
celebration when that happens
i love that and what for those that are
interested in binance us where can they
go
to uh to sign up for an account yeah
sign up is binance.us
that's the easiest way and we've also
got an app in the app store both google
play and ios
apple store and you can follow us on
twitter
at binance us or at cryptocoly and we've
also got a telegram community which is
quite lively
i'm in it every saturday morning and
well every morning
um so you can always hear from us and
ask us questions and if you ask when
your state will give you
the website for the answer too i love
that
and then camilla you've got a whole
bunch of stuff going on
from the newsletter that you write every
day to
the book where can people go find both
of those
yeah so my newsletter the defiant is the
defined.substance.com
the book is on amazon and and really any
any book seller out there
uh so yeah just uh go on amazon type the
infinite machine
and click buy um and yeah you can find
me on twitter
at connie russo
the buy button is really important for
uh for a book i'm glad you put that part
in there
it's a key it's a key piece you need a
summer reading book
uh book list kind of like oprah's book
list and uh
make make everyone do a bit of summer
reading there's some good books coming
out so appreciate the work
awesome guys listen go uh go use finance
us go
and uh get camilla's new book the
infinite machine
and uh make sure that before you leave
you're not allowed to leave this live
stream unless you click on the like
button because that's how more people
will find out about the book
find out about finance us and find about
bitcoin and crypto
so smash the like button and we will see
you guys
next time thanks so much bob